cities have been named after it
economies have been built on it
wars have been fought over and your life
depends on it salt may be the most
important and the most divisive mineral
in history what is it worth to us today
this is what if and here's what would
happen if there were no salt in the
world there are more than 14,000 uses
for salt but to most of us it only means
one thing high blood pressure back in
the day your salary might have been paid
in salt
it could have preserved your food healed
your wounds and brought good fortune
today beyond being the reason why that
burger that pretzel and those french
fries taste so good right now
salt is important for de-icing chemical
processing water treatment farming and
for several uses in the oil and gas
industry it's also made up of two
elements that on their own kill you but
together they keep you alive want to see
what happens when you put sodium in
water
do you know what chlorine does to you
well when you put this and this together
you get table salt also known as sodium
chloride to deadly elements combined
into one
you can't live without salt has a number
of crucial benefits like helping your
body transmit nerve signals so that your
muscles can relax and contract enabling
your heart to pump blood it's also
important for digesting nutrients and
fighting infections but hold on there
mister peanut you can have too much of a
good thing while low blood sodium make
us fatigue vomiting seizures or even
death too much salt can end up
accumulating between your cells
thickening your blood making your heart
work harder
and often resulting in cardiac arrest
your body naturally has about 40
teaspoons of salt in it or roughly 0.4%
of your body weight but every time you
cry sweat or pee you lose some of that
salt and it needs to be replaced the
American Heart Association recommends
that adults get between 1,500 to 2300
milligrams of salt per day but that only
amounts to one bag of chips or two
California rolls meanwhile that burger
and fries you are eyeing have about
3,400 milligrams so maybe you're
thinking it's time to start cutting back
on your salt intake well sure but don't
cut it all out in the 1930s dr. Robert
McCants of Cambridge University's
Department of experimental medicine got
four volunteers to go ten days without
salt first he had them sweat out all the
salt in their bodies
then he literally desalinated everything
they consumed
it wasn't long before the participants
began to realize they weren't tasting
much flavor in anything then fatigue set
in and they became too tired to even eat
signs of hyponatremia started to show
which basically means that your blood
cells start swelling because there's not
enough salt in your blood to regulate
how much water a cell will consume left
untreated hyponatremia can result in
seizures coma and death at the end of
the trial participants were given salty
foods and within minutes they could
taste again and their energy quickly
came back if that's just ten days
without salt imagine if it simply ceased
to exist we wouldn't last very long and
not just us plants and animals need salt
as much as we do the mere desalinization
of our oceans would wipe out all our
underwater algae cutting photosynthesis
on earth in half land-based plant life
would follow and soon we'd be facing an
issue of too much carbon dioxide and not
enough oxygen our climate would go crazy
fluctuating between extreme hot and cold
temperatures with a dramatic surge in
hurricanes of course to mulches weather
food shortages and a lack of oxygen
would be even harder to process since
you'd also be suffering from dizzying
headaches vomiting and extreme fatigue
any numbness or chest pain you might
experience is probably an oncoming heart
attack but instead of running for an
overcrowded hospital get to the nearest
convenience store if you're lucky there
will still be some chips and Gatorade
left on the shelves but that's assuming
that no one else who's feeling totally
helpless in the face of this mass
desalinization event has seen this video
look it's never going to happen but
you'll be prepared for anything as long
as you keep watching what if
[Music]